Hi there.
Welcome to the complete guide to InfluxDB
two.
This is the first tutorial
we are gonna take a look at how
you install InfluxDB two.
In the course materials, you will find a
README. Md inside of the to dash installing
InfluxDB
directory.
Here, you will find the instructions on how
to install InfluxDB two on macOS,
on Debian and Ubuntu via the provided
Debian repository,
on Red Hat,
running with Docker,
and installing on Kubernetes via Helm.
We're going to run through each of these
installation mechanisms
right now.
First up, macOS.
We can jump over to our terminal, can
run brew install
InfluxDB
just like so.
In a few seconds to a minute, this
will download the InfluxDB two binaries and install
them and make them available on macOS.
Now we don't want to start InfluxDB as
a service for today because you more than
likely are not installing InfluxDB
to production on your Mac machine. This will
be purely for development experience.
So we can copy this command here to
run InfluxDB
in the foreground.
This will run the InfluxDB database on port
eight zero eight six, which you can then
hit through your browser.
There we go.
And now we are presented with the welcome
screen to InfluxDB
two.
Okay.
Method two, installing InfluxDB two to Debian and
Debian derivative
operating systems.
The first thing we want to do is
import the trusted GPG key, which is available
from InfluxDB
repository's website. We can do this via wget,
and then we have to de armor,
which means to take
the text representation
of the key and convert it to the
binary representation
of the key, which apt requires.
We can copy this command and paste it
like so.
And just so you can see what I
mean,
if we run w get on this key,
you will see the text based representation.
And if we run
the fill command again,
if
we run the fill command again without the
redirect to a fail, you will see the
binary representation
of the key.
And this is just what AMP prefers and
requires.
Next, we use the LSB release command
in order to understand which Debian or Debian
derivative like Ubuntu
version we have access to.
We can actually just echo
both of these values to see
that this is in fact Ubuntu focal.
Lastly, we can echo the required lane to
our sources fail to tell Debian or Ubuntu
how to access this repository.
If we cat this fail, we will see
that lane interpolated
with the two
environment variables
that we just echoed.
We can see that we tell Debian or
apt,
this is the key that this repository is
signed with. We are running on a bin
to focal and we want this DB impact,
this table package.
From here, we can run an app update
and install InfluxDB
two.
Now we can run InfluxDB
to start our InfluxDB database.
We give this just a few moments again.
We will see the log messages, and we
should be able to hit this on localhost
8086.
And there we are. Now method three, installing
InfluxDB
to Red Hat and Red Hat derivative operating
system.
Much like we did for Debian,
we need to be able to add a
repository
to the system.
With Red Hat, that involves adding
something to the etcetera slash yum dot repos
dot d directory.
Here, we tell it where to find the
repository,
where to find the key, and then we
use DNF to install the package.
We can copy all of this,
drop it into our Red Hat system.
We'll be prompted to import the GPG key,
and the installation should work nice and simple.
And done.
The same as we did for others, we
can run InfluxDB
and just a few moments logs will start
to output and we'll be able to hit
port 8086
on localhost to browse to InfluxDB.
Perfect.
Method four, run an InfluxDB
with Docker.
I'm using Docker today, but the keys commands
will work for most other runtimes.
The first thing we're going to do
is create a volume so that the data
that we write to InfluxDB will be persisted
during recreates,
restarts,
etcetera.
This is not a production setup, and production
container based setups will be covered in a
future video.
Now let's create our Docker volume named InfluxDB.
Next, we need to run the container image.
We do this exposing port eight zero eight
six
and mounting an or volume to the Varlib
InfluxDB location,
and we specify the version of InfluxDB two
that we want to run. The latest is
two zero seven.
This will just pull the image, start the
process,
and with our port mapping of eight zero
eight six, we should be able to browse
to this container from our browser.
Perfect.
Installing on Kubernetes with Helm.
The first thing you have to do is
add the Helm repository to your local system.
We can do this with the Helm repo
add command.
Next, we use Helm upgrade dash dash install
followed by a release name. Here, I'm using
InfluxDB two.
Then the chart that we wish to install,
InfluxDataInfluxDB
two.
We are not providing any CLI
or value YAML based overrides or configuration to
tweak the deployment of this Helm chart. We
will cover such in production deployments in a
subsequent video.
We hit return to use all the default
values,
and Helm will install InfluxDB2
to our cluster.
We can use this little bit of information
at the end to get the admin password
for this deployment.
This is randomly generated
via the Helm chart when you first deploy.
The next thing we need to do is
be able to port forward to our cluster
to browse to this locally.
We use kubectl port forward mapping eight zero
eight six and the container to eight zero
eight six on my local machine.
I will copy the password
up over here.
Admin.
Perfect.
And that is installing InfluxDB
two. We took a look at Mac OS
with Homebrew.
Debian and Ubuntu using the official repositories.
Using the official repositories for Red Hat and
Red Hat derivatives,
Docker, and Kubernetes.